There's been a great deal of enthusiasm about the rebirth of comedy and satire in America.
One of the first to prove that there is an audience for literate and devastating humor is my guest today.
Sometimes called the king of the sacred cow punches. Mr Mort Sahl.
This is so for three years before you got your first break I understand you were earning an average of
about forty six dollars from your a year from your performances in writing what kept you going.
I was waiting for this rebirth I still keep me going what rebirth.
Well you began it and then there was a whole group of
comedians such as name a mike
like I remember them with you if you have time which one of them has
to do with any rebirth. Mike Nichols is a director and Elaine May as a writer
I try to see them perform their work anywhere. Let me do for a
while where when they had a show write a New York Review and they did something
about high school people necking and something about
Freud I'd hardly call it social reform. I don't agree with you but the comedians of
all I think as a matter of fact they're delinquent as citizens. The
only time they're interested in politics is when their star struck with the president and they're invited to the White House which is
a containment policy
anyway. What do you mean the comedian has to be socially concerned in the so she
was former He not only has to be a social reformer I mean if he wants to be but he has to
be critical of his colleagues like a good psychiatrist. Well fire. Well I just.
I think they're delinquent citizens. I think they look the other way I think they're a moral.
Was someone like Lenny Bruce is criticized for looking so hard in
deciding critics criticizing it so violently does anyway I
mean tolerate He has the morality of a fifteen year old. I mean squares don't know what he's talking about and
hit people that occurred to them when they were twelve. There's nothing profound about what he
does but you cannot waste your time you only got so much time as an adult and you have to listen to
a
lumination there's nothing happening with that in other words. I kind of entertainment I just don't think
it's in lightning and it's not social reform I think people confuse KRON ology
a lot of people came along about the same time. But let's give the audience about not the performers the
audience showed that there was an appetite that demonstrated that the performers didn't meet the appetite.
You were implying that you are the only one is meeting the appetite.
Well I do what I do. I've been defending that for the last ten years but the thing
that I do is concerned with you know that's concerned by itself
but one of those one I'm shot down in flames I go down on the plane alone I don't see a lot
of company when I'm doing well I hear about this group this new wave there is NO
NO WAY.
What about the Second City fridges that's political satire.
No it is and when when did you ever see in the political side that. Oh I've never
seen
any they do they do ones on the on the candidates and on their Also social satire
and psychology on. Phony lovers and
well all but all of that is safe. It's only daring
if you know it's not very daring to come into New York and do jokes about a segregationist it's
all safe. I don't none of that shakes me up. I find that very and you know I'm speaking not as
a comedian but as a member of the
audience. Do you mean that you would demand that they go after the political and social ills of the time
in this with what are you only make demands on myself I don't make any demands on anyone else we're doing it right now
I
mean no one's no no no I although that's definitely something in the man's whistle is not the same
as payment on demand. You can't make a demand for someone who has no funds. Let me put it that way.
You know making demands but in order for you to approve what would you like to
see
the comedian be doing all of the should do whatever they like that they are that's up to them whether it's Jerry Lewis
or Jonathan Winters whoever let him do what they want to do but they should not pass themselves as
Embraer pass themselves off as improvisational or satirical satire is a pretty good word you know when you say that
I'm thinking about people like Mark
Twain is nobody of that caliber today. I don't see the.
I know because I have nights off and I go out to see people. I don't call it satirical to talk
about sex in the suburbs. That's not satire that's nonsense it's playing footsie under
the table. What is
said satire
is a literarily based X.
ray of the society. It's an onslaught. It's an attack and believe me
this country needs an attack this country needs a critic. So the best thing you could have is a critic on
staff that would mean we're alive and we're vital.
This is how you see things need to be attacked society needs to be attacked to
fix most of all what aspects. You know. Well many aspects need to be attacked and in
other words the whole value system needs to be scrutinized whether or not people are acquisitive has to
be scrutinized not just politics.
People have to other words political interpretations or if a sociological interpretation. Whether
or not the roles are changing between men and women in America. Why monogamy
is crumbling in the western world not only in America we have to find
out why you wish to find out about violence.
We have to find out a lot of things we have to listen with a thirty year. Dr Reichs and if we can
develop
one. Does the you rest or do you try to eliminate or
to reform I mean what is the what's the importance of
it. What's the importance of what I have to ask the critics are right
about the importance is that I can do it that's the mirror.
What do you hope to achieve is put it that way whether you do it or not.
Well I'm accepted on my own terms. A lot of people in the audience who think what I think but
because of the social structure and certain restrictions imposed by themselves upon
themselves they are accountants and
executives and taxi drivers and everything else and I happen to have
because a psychological reaction
probably have found this out but I can articulate so I speak for them the day I
stop speaking for them and only for myself I probably will. Be
working well you said you've got to examine when asked to examine such things as
the changing role women should stand for size and the values.
Granted you have to examine what have you come up with what system if you come up with
yourself what the system was what our values. What system of values I come up
with well I say I mean it's apparent that certain values. You know
I tripped over because they were there. There was old as the rocks I didn't discover them.
I rediscovered them because they have meant obfuscated under a Cross station
of debris in our society today there are only
certain things you cling
to whether you recognise a virtue. Whether you recognize decency.
Whether you are loyal certain values that's all what you're capable of not
running away. Whether you're more in your own way than other people are in your
way and and whether or not you can deal with other people and their
words what is emerging as a human being your own man being honest yourself what do you mean
by being your own man's most important thing for anybody being your own person that's tough. I mean that
when you meet someone who is sane and level and has
balance of
values. I don't think that normal means average. It's
an achievement to be a normal human being and should not be passed off civilised
people should be prized that's what I
mean and you would normally you would be in my normal. I don't
know
I mean that's a pretty That would be a subjective. Are
you your own men very much so very much my own
man wasn't making
normal in the way you describe it the values are not particularly secure. I mean
they're very obvious ones that
you know people obscure them and then the they are not obscure to begin with look
at traditional They only become radical when people try to obfuscate them for
instance. I'm my own man but that's. All of it that's only act
one act two is doesn't all fit into place what does it cost to
be your own man. If you get on the stage twice a night for forty five
minutes and you have to pay for it by being in pain the rest of the
day in a conflict with people. That's an excess of cost and possibly
an unnecessary. You know not
necessary to have to examine not just to find out so being your own man is only
act one is act two and I three.
Do you find that there's much resistance to the point of view that you
have and
express and sometimes there is but it depends if you're ahead of yourself in
other words if I have a view of the world and other people don't have the
view they will reject
it. I mean I would think everyone would ascribe to the view human decency and honesty.
Well you know if you put it down like that if I was a Boy Scout. I mean that if you make
a remark about
a public figure. And you get resistance from the audience. That doesn't mean they
don't agree with you it has come to mean that they
do. And it's like people know that someone
they resent it when they know somebody isn't making it and you remind them and
one of their reactions is to pull away only a naive performer would say. Well I've said
something they don't agree
with it's not that it's that they do agree with it they know another or just some people they
don't know at all and there's some people they know all too well and that's the
difference since it did after the Eisenhower administration.
And frame of
mind was over that you know some of the inspiration in Morden see
for your for your jokes you think this is too little who said it. Oh
it's Redan and your comment
but
was you're qualified as gospel. No I'm
just a matter of fact the two best records I made in my
opinion were made during the Kennedy. Strange
but they're all fair game. There's no utopians there's no
imminent danger of utopia in the government and the only
people that say that are usually Democrats who don't want to hear a Democrat attacked. So
then they tell you that jokes
about Eisenhower funny. That's because they have no mercy toward.
Vice President
Nixon and they're scared to death that the lose. They have
fallen idols in a Democratic Party. I'm not scared to death. That's
my secret.
I just did your opinions about some of the candidates for office. How do you like
Goldwater Goldwater's too easy all the comedians are going to make jokes about
Goldwater Goldwater is a temptation because he looks like an
extreme socially irresponsible performers are going to make jokes about
him but the more subtle areas and the greater threats are the people
who are going to run and if you're responsible adult you should get into you
know one I should say one should get
into that area. We don't have to start with an extreme Republican
we should start with the Democratic Party. Well let's start with Johnson and the Democrats were the
ones you know who ridiculed him when he was the vice president about his not being
around all of these great satirists on a program called that was the week that was
Rose telling him. JOHNSON You know the vanishing American where you see the vice president has vanished.
Now they're telling me he's wonderful why can't we just that rapidly. I don't fall in love at first
sight with anybody.
Johnson was elected to Congress in one nine hundred thirty six I believe he's been in politics all his life and
suddenly found himself in
government and there's a wide gulf involved
there and he received the next we heard he had received the stereo said from Bobby
Baker and then. He would have been better off accepting components because he
could put them in the closet along with Bobby Baker in the entire affair.
Now and now we. He we hear that you know he is the only candidate that
the Democratic Party has
so. I would that seems odd you know I thought the Democratic Party was.
You know abundant and wonderful people of Middle East to hear the Democrats say it but they CAN
I wonder how far the Democrats can
rationalize before they say anything they went from Roosevelt to
Truman to Stevenson to Kennedy to Johnson.
They're just going to keep going. I think you could
bring you can I once said that I believe
cruise ship could be nominated on the Democratic ticket by there saying he's better
than Nixon. That's the whole Democrats all facade. They have no program except
Who else is there which is hardly a program. I'd never get married on that
basis. So there's Johnson I guess I get a feel Romney hasn't told us yet we don't know yet.
So once he ends the suspense. But politics you know politics a part of the Act Some nights
I don't do it at
all Lou else you said not the extremists. You should begin with like the
water what about Rockefeller how do you feel about him would govern
Iraq a vote
Yeah well he's probably a right wing social democrat. I mean I have
a system of categories you know I should explain to
you that house we have eighty one categories it makes it simple. It simplifies it for me.
Governor Rockefeller is as a matter of fact is closer to the Kennedy line of thinking than the president
is that's one of the ironies of our time have a Republican leader who is left of the
Democratic president.
It's only ironic if you believe in the system in the system. What system. Anyway it's anarchic
in
effect Governor Rockefeller is. The governor of a feller
who lives in this apartment house and Nixon as I understood it that was generically that's what started that
in the same apartment house and his ex-wife rocky and his friends live in this apartment
house then there's. He then went to New Hampshire where the
people I the press interprets. Defeat up there is the fact that people didn't like the fact that he got
married that's considered immoral getting married in the circles I grew up in that's considered very
moral there are more immoral acts than not and then getting married
but Rocky and happy everybody has a nickname
Ladybird happy. Jackie we have a lot of that they don't go much for
grace in this era and I don't mean capital G.. But first
ladies you know going by grace by the way I want to make a point here.
There's a broker's attitude in America that's very
unhealthy it goes like it's a broker's attitude about winning people say that
guy hasn't got a chance but they never evaluate that guy unquote That's
in italics that. Term that
guy they go by ratings I watched Soandso show it had the highest rating on
television but they don't they never lament the fact that something worthwhile had a
low rating. They just kind of want to get with the winners I never have understood that. But
it's more prevalent now than it is ever been in the last in the last ten years and I've
noticed it's become more prevalent. We have widespread throughout the country
people's brokers' attitude. Rockefeller doesn't have a chance that the first ones if he were elected would be standing in line to
say shake hands with the president.
These people were ridiculing Johnson as a man who wasn't vice president Robert Kennedy was a
vice president in fact now they turn around and they're saying we're certainly lucky to have him at the helm.
If you could use anybody in the whole in the
whole country not even when necessarily that's running whom might you think you have any ideas on that.
Well yeah I have a lot of ideas and I just don't have been tasered so would be to display
them now I can't believe that in a country of two hundred million
people in the United States America's richest country in world. I can believe all the talent available
to us from William O. Douglas to Dr Oppenheimer to all the people in
the lab but Cal Tech that the greatest person. We
have is Senator Johnson. Besides if he's president is going to run that majority since
he ran it so well everyone discovered they didn't say that when he was running it.
It's wonderful how retrospect hindsight is beautiful Monday morning quarterbacks
and kashrus Clay is the champion great leadership when you're going to run for office. I'm not interested in
politics you know I'm going to do a play in the fall.
What did you just take what did you decide in Sydney. Bruce Bruce things when we know what is
about what's on the left of this generation and it's about a guy who is his own man and
it's something that I you know it's a different way to say something I don't want to be an
actor and I wouldn't be looking for a play if I wasn't doing this which is very
special with your role in it I my role is it's me if I had gone to
write instead of run.
It's Lorraine Hansberry's first place since Raisin in the sun so the reader merino and it's it's going to be a
very exciting play as it's a real bite because it says something talks about the nobility of man it
has to do with something.
It's not another homosexual song in the
theatre and you see many shows and you've been
you're watching a working seven days so you know you know I try to see
something when I mean the last time I was here I went to the theatre a couple of times
and listen to your shows I have to wait till I come to Los Angeles to see them but the New
York theater is highly overrated the snobbery is not
justified and it's usually indulged in by people who have gone and promoted going
to Hollywood and then find the fashionable to wrap Hollywood after accepting its
gifts and coming back
here when it's not so overrated now because all they talk about is how sick the theater is
now about it is it is a very bad business is not overrated they're diagnosing
the malice there.
Look at the the Actors Studio they get enough publicity here to make that I mean they
do buy a dynamite and I play one performance I mean
what right do they have to look down on other people based on what. Their job is to communicate
with the audience I know the audience gets in their hair and bothers them but they're. That is that's the
theater when you get up and talk and there's an audience that's the answer and that's all of it would be for
your interest. What aspects or what would you like about
it anyway your communicate ideas the people and it doesn't mean they have to accept them just so that
they're shook up they you leave them with something residual when they leave I don't care if they disagree they can write
letters but the big thing is that either reinforce their own prejudice or they change their mind so
they change yours or whatever but it's an interchange of ideas that's what it's
for and until we have coffee houses again we'll have to settle. But they are bringing change
or ideas.
What do you seen recently that you think
better ideas young man man from you please.
Probably but if you
like Who's Afraid of Virginia moved to D.C. I don't like it because that is a
pretty critical view of the
changing roles of men and women by someone who hasn't practiced marriage as you know as well he's
a critic of it but you don't have to practice everything you criticize your critique
of politics you know the politician.
Well yeah but that's I don't think that that analogy holds up that's the
obvious analogy but I don't think that holds up. I didn't stand up and
say it's anarchy. All politicians are corrupt there is no hope there's no note of hope in
that place that there is no way out I don't accept
that you are you an optimist you think there is you
know you got out of bed this morning I must if I were
an e-list I wouldn't take the trouble to say I'm one on the my on the on the show.
Do you think that things are getting better.
Yes slowly. Not quickly enough that's the only complaint I have and
the feeling impatience I display of course they are getting better there are several signs that they're getting better
but boy is that an uphill fight. You know we're swimming through blue a tough time a lot
of impediments going.
It's tough. We're paying an excessive cost for what we accomplish because we're buying time.
What kind of things. Indicated improvement in
conditions. Well when a guy
like Marlon Brando was the highest paid actor in Hollywood and he's also the
best director. It's good you know he's not off Broadway somewhere obscure
and people can go down there and say well I like him but he's not commercial that's good
and when I can say what I say and have a large audience that's
encouraging these are in the areas
of theater
when if you think money ran to become
successful doesn't become less good. Since the early days.
That's a typical middle class right wing
social democratic reaction as any three if you're eighty when you think you know you know a lot of other words on a list that's the
same old thing though of course he got better the more he was encouraged to have more confidence he worked
more and he was unsteady your feet so the speak in other words you
equate success with corruption and that's not a problem with just the military in this case
so I wasn't convinced he
was getting better since he was getting more
popular done right is getting better is the best we
have one nothing a minute be this we had been I don't think Mutiny on the bounty
or the American is going to say the wild one or
so I'll go into line for line with Marlon Brando
One Eyed Jacks is the best directorial job I've ever seen in a motion picture bar
none including David
Lean for whom I have the upmost respect I worship his work. I believe
that the performance in the body is a
virtuoso performance. He's one of the greatest comedians we have on
screen great sense of comedy most actors are cumbersome in comedy.
He's brilliant. There are twenty seven separate scripts on bounty and he should not have to pick up the tab for
that that's not his fault that confusion.
He's always convincing and remember his virtue is that he brings something to a role he brings something to it so
the Steve McQueen.
The people who come in and are themselves are not acting. He brings something to a role and
he takes a chance and I tried the ugly American and perhaps you feel we missed but he tried
the courage to look to inspect and to try
to lift things to be uplifting is a moral person.
What are the sons of Marlon Brando and and
you. Well you know didn't limit
the world that I know that size and your view of this.
Which is unfair when you're doing a review of this tape as you
conducted me and I just there's going to be a moderator are you going to choose up sides. If
you want to debate with me. That'll be different then you'll probably lose because
I know this
area but you know I'm not you know I'm not I don't know my
boxing gloves on here. There are several signs in other words we signed
a limited test ban with the Russians. We know
that we also know that their adventure early
so minority groups are going to come into their own in this country. Whatever the
motivation
on the civil rights bill is it's being I think the bill is a
joke and the bill is a joke it's an exercise in motion a cathartic
step for some people it's profit for separationist be they white
or dark and it's candy coated it has
no teeth in it it's just a term but it's a start. Or
I could say
the president's getting civil rights off to a whopping stop.
What do you think about the mystique you know the idea that women
should express themselves in careers.
Well there's a lot that's that's valid in Betty Friedan's book but there's a lot that
isn't and it's one of you know it's the remarks are made in a very strident
tone although I agree with many of them. It's just that her sumption in
some areas or the women who read it assume probably
that they have something to say see I think women are frauds in the sense
that they're too competitive. In America. And they don't have anything to offer.
It's bad enough to be competitive when you marry a guy but when you really don't want to compete then you're a hypocrite.
You're a
liar women allies say oh I want to do this and I wanted to they don't want to do that
they are female impersonators they don't want to be girls but they don't want to be men
either because that's tough yet to perform when you're a man and it is not in the nature of
women to perform. It's very tough on
them and it was all women are really worried about is being abandoned men are the
ones who have to perform and they do have to
perform whether it is in business or in the
service to be
brave or they have to be noble in their public life or whether they have to perform.
You know in the act of love or whatever to be graphic. Men have to perform.
Women have to kind of organize life. But they don't want to do that so they say well you know
I don't know a chance to express myself and I become the protest group. I don't I don't believe See
I don't think they really want to
I don't think that they really want to compete ask you know you don't have to ask me ask
somebody who's well equipped
ask the psychology department at Columbia. Ask any of the people up there wouldn't people
graduate school the dependency rate with women. So if they don't have figures to accommodate their view that
women are not dependable they marry them they're back in school and they're out of school ask them up
there and their fellows who are not biased many of them are
therapists. This is selling in your act to use a lot of psychological terminology. Do you
take psychology very seriously if you study did.
I don't know anything I don't know I've studied I well I mean I have to in school but not
twenty great degree. I I do that as a kind of a put on that's the kid
the generation that's a sideways poke in the ribs at the elbow in the ribs It sounds
like a restaurant advertising men would drink in New
York advertisement will drink most anywhere New York that's the wonderful thing about them they have a universality.
No I use terms. Put on to reflect the generation that uses the terms
doesn't know what they mean. Most people think that's valid I don't know what I'm talking about that's you
know it's just like people use a musician's language are very rarely. Hip.
They're usually happen. You play a lot of big clubs now like Copacabana you New York.
Do you find the audiences there appreciate your stuff as much as when you were in smaller
smaller places.
It's a commercial venture the owners were not back in the air force of didn't get to the audiences
but if I'm really rooting for my side the gotta get through to people you
can't discriminate against them and put them into a small room and say that's the only
way the Blue Angels nothing but expense accounts and guys with white socks
but people think that that's very intellectualized and hip on the side and it's
not Wherever there are people and a microphone you can work.
You know it's tough to be the first one
in but you've got to do it if you believe in what you're doing. If you just choose
your shots you're not a champion. Thank you very much.